here we are behind the scenes  with loki loki here he is  that's me  it's this really big story with a  mixture of tones and genres loki is the  god of mischief we have to do  mischievous things we're creating real  mayhem  bye  the tva oversees the sacred timeline and  keeps the order  what if you take a character who  represents chaos and he put him in that  world  you can trust me  oh you've literally stabbed people on  the back like 50 times  i'd never do it again  this is something i didn't think marvel  was ever done it is very different the  audience will be really excited  this is the good part  i love the action there's interesting  characters there's twists and turns it's  awe-inspiring what could possibly go  wrong  [Music]  what did you expect